welcome to this video playing da fresh
from Antarctica and don't believe that
really arraignment kaufman son american
player not mistaken the son of mary
kaufman the former world senior champion
the author from some chess engines okay
in books of course so I'm playing the
Sun let's see we got a zimage probably
and yeah yeah to go out for him to
capture on c3 surprisingly okay so c5 at
96 are the normal ways to go also some
some players to play d 65 which is not
so bad very very close to set up in the
center but these six is by far the most
common way to play okay so we have the
set up with e5
yes he five yeah I don't necessarily
need to tailor need to play md5 but the
clothes Center structure is normally
quite okay for white especially if I
have not cancelled that means i can
easily gain even more space here on the
Kings side and that will play g4 in
dodgeville if he allows me to do that
okay let's see g4 or not yeah I guess I
like to prepare this a bit get some
pieces developed first but g4 h4 is what
I'd like to do let's see huh so it's
trying to trying to prevent that by
intending to place an ID on their forum
I can do here though if you place f5 I
have the capture and oh that's weird
yeah well okay maybe he didn't have any
any move to prevent g4 let's see G fry
can maybe play night h4 that I can just
castle if everything else fails queen
age for check this Bishop f2 losing
peace and night therefore i can really
just take this is just just a pawn with
no particular compensation for black
count if he retreats and this was
complete nonsense night h5 I really
don't know what he should have done yeah
yeah this is just the poem don't think
this is sufficient maybe maybe you could
have played Queen f6 though Queen f6 was
interesting okay yeah by can I can take
these six this is not okay if you can
take here Queenie to queen bee to check
okay maybe not this one but if I'm just
cover it I mean he must cover this Excel
don't really I don't really see him
sacrificing this as well
you know what kind of counter play this
black half the problem is the only one I
can think of this b5 opening up the B
file but it's not so easy to do yeah
yeah here thus the g5 is the problem oh
come on come on a net mod lose time
opening up the g5 for an attack it's
better to attack him directly and not
waste any time
yes 10 what I was trying to say it's not
so easy for him to to get be five in
with some effective counter play F my
king is in the center but it's shielded
by many pawns okay of course I am I want
to open the position so let's just get
ahead here quickly I could also go e5
whether this is this is not bad just the
tech g6 no good way to protect it rook
g1e five maybe e5 was even better not
sure okay but now if five-year Queen
each Queen age 7 s quite quite black
resigned why the problem yeah yeah this
was an opening opening disaster I am he
needs to do something else here or queen
f6 maybe queen f6 I we both overlook
that I think it played this and this is
maybe not not so clear here Queen f6 I I
didn't see that move at all at first but
this is much better than what he did I
mean after that I think why does
basically just winning at least with
good technical play should win the game
he's just a pawn down and was there
there are this attacking ideas and no
come to play but Queenie of six was
interesting attacking this one I have
Moscow here and then the question is if
he can can you take him again yeah this
is what you must try and probably so
maybe also good for white but it's far
this is a messy position
which at least an enum fast the time
control game gives much better chances
than the the one you played let's say
here if I take 95 this is getting
somewhat somewhat messy our Knight f3
may be taking you know I may be should
should play something like that instead
what we ate I don't know movie back to
the 80 so then Queen here Bishop back it
guess it should be good for white but
it's it's a bit messing this message
this position and this was basically
basically over i think down he has no
counter play whatsoever yeah maybe Queen
f7 SS a bit tougher but I can I just
pile up on the G violent after Queen
trade f3 f3 and f4 will be played very
soonish ok thanks for watching